i'm coming for you come on
this isn't banter between mates it's a
sign
of a police force accepting it has
issues engaging with the community it
serves
and trying to do more that's life that's
good
a year ago these officers watched the
video showing the final moments of
george floyd's life
it kind of feels like your candle is
being burnt on both ends so you feel the
pain from the black community and as a
black man seeing
someone you could recognize as a friend
cousin brother or even yourself
but then you also have the professional
disappointment of i know how it's
supposed to be done
and seeing it go so horribly wrong i
mean both sides of
both sides of your very person are
screaming almost at odds with each other
no one understands those dueling
loyalties more than the forces most
senior female officer the uniform
represents something to our community
but karen geddes believes george floyd's
death has sparked real change
but what i've seen in police training is
a conversation with staff around
how we go into incidents how we
understand historical context
so if one thing george floyd has had an
impact on within policing
it's definitely changing how we train
and upskill our staff around cultural
competence
wait wait wait wait wait wait he didn't
do anything in the last 12 months
high-profile stop and search videos have
gone viral
leading to questions about police
tactics
it's an interesting experience being
stopped by the police
my name is nathaniel james i'm a stopper
nathaniel has been stopped and searched
over 300 times
he now runs a workshop helping young
people understand the law
and their rights there's been other
situations here
where like police officers have put me
in handcuffs here never asked me a
question
if you're black you're almost nine times
more likely
to be stopped and searched by the police
so how many of you guys
have been stopped and searched by the
police at this workshop
it's clear that negative experiences
have detrimental impacts
on the relationship between both
communities there's a lot of distrust
they're paranoid they don't know their
rights they feel like
some of them feel like they've been
extorted in
in a sense one solution could be to
recruit more black
officers about seventeen percent of our
recruits now from uh
black and ethnic military communities i
think that is a good start
but the population is 35 and probably
higher
the numbers of black officers playing is
awfully poor
um so we one percent of our officers are
black about one percent of our recruits
are we're not going to change the force
and so we you know kind of just coming
up to a year into that recruitment
process
we're doing a lot of work looking at
what more we can do but even with a more
representative force there's still the
problem of reversing
years of mistrust would you ever
consider a career in the police bus
not personally no right i think
[Music]
there's a lot of work that needs to be
done in the police force there's a lot
of things that need to be changed
i think there needs to be uh it needs to
be changed from the top down
you mean no no no it's just not really
my thing to be honest that you know it's
not really my
yeah i mean now i wouldn't join my
friend a community which feels
over-policed and
under-protected and a force trying hard
to change
no worries at all you stay safe shaman
freeman-powell
sky news birmingham